there are four essential things if you
want to win on the internet
in 2021 let's get into it
everybody's so obsessed with is this
gonna be around
yeah i don't care if it's gonna be
around right now
is the radio station to be around yes no
who gives a [ __ ]
tell me where everybody's attention is
the streets
yeah where it's underpriced listen i
want a tv show
wait hold on go ahead clarify please
people when you say underpriced
you just talk about like attention so
attention
where's under what i call underpriced
attention instagram influencers
if you take all 300 million americans
and you ask them to sell this bottled
water
and they had unlimited budget everybody
had a
million dollars how would they sell it i
believe that 90
of americans would make a tv commercial
or do a billboard
when that's some [ __ ] correct yeah
what i would do with my money is i would
give it to a bunch of influencers on
instagram
and i would make one or two great videos
for facebook three minutes long
and that's what i would do and that's
exactly what these big corporations is
doing like nike
uh even with adidas with me grabbing me
to do a sneakers like they're grabbing
these
influences or correct social christ
because you know what it is
you're underpriced and they can get you
of course because just like me my book
my book sells 100 000 copies in a week
i'm making them money
they give me a 3 million dollar advance
i'm happy right because i'm using them
as a bank
you're using adidas as a bank right
you're getting the advance up front
but that but it's like the label i'm
using the labels that's all it is
that's all it is that's all by the way
you lose i'm using y'all as a bank
that's all it is that all that's all it
is so what i do
is i care only about them i only care
i love you about miranda i only care
about king david i
only care about nicholas i only care
about fala i only cared about that
because they're explaining that matter
right because they're the attention
arbitrage and that's why i give them so
much love and that's why i give all my
business advice away for free
because i want to be more valuable to
them than they are to me right
so underpriced attention to me is things
like the super bowl in america cost
six million dollars and i think it's
unbelievably underpriced
because a hundred million people will
watch your commercial
meanwhile i think a regular commercial
on the telly
is overpriced because there's
assumptions about
grps and nielsen ratings that i just
know are not true
in common sense facebook organic used to
be the greatest thing in the world
it doesn't even exist anymore it's an ad
product
running the ads on facebook as we do and
we took tune of hundreds of millions of
dollars
there's a lot of ways to make it
underpriced it's by doing contextual
creative at scale
and doing 80 different media spends
instead of one
there's ways to make it overpriced on
linkedin youtube facebook where you just
do one video
and you just try to reach everybody 18
to 55. so
i spend my life being religious around
where's the nook and cranny that allows
me to pay five cents
that is really worth 20 cents on
business
in a minefield where there's a lot of
places you can spend 20 cents
and only get five cents value that's
what i mean by underpriced attention so
for me one of the things that really
stands out
is if i was asking the normal
quote-unquote person
to produce 100 pieces of content a day i
guarantee you that i'm probably
subconsciously thinking that 50 of those
are twitter
you can write you can retweet and add
your two cents
all of a sudden you're kind of there
right
the other thing is i don't think people
understand document versus create i
think people think
you need drock or jason following your
dust and following you around
i think it's just taking a picture like
i see
content right here like i see content
and maybe i have
this is probably my strength i see
content in everything
i think you should take a photo of us
talking right now and tweet it and be
like
holy [ __ ] i'm doing this with garyvee
right now yeah like like i didn't i took
it
before you came in but like there's
madison square garden yeah and you know
like
like this is new york you know like like
i think there's a lot more content and
by the way
i think that could be done 15 to 20
times on twitter
instagram stories and tick tock without
any cost to the preciousness
that is the main reason that everybody
can't make 100 pieces of content okay
you know taking a photo of what you see
and adding one sentence is allowing
people into your world
and you start creating around common
interests the you know a lot of people
like gary should i separate my business
in life i'm like i put my jets content
in my all my content
i put my garage sale stuff there that
has nothing to do with the marketing or
the business running like
i think it's there but i do think it's a
strategy mindset
and i think everybody thinks this is
useless and nobody would care
and i think you should let them decide
you're in the content business
every [ __ ] artist ever sucked
until they put a banger out exactly
like everybody sucked until they put out
a song
that made them not suck alanis more set
nobody knew
killed it you understand it's as simple
as that and now that you've soundcloud
and [ __ ] spotify and youtube
there's no more a and rs and [ __ ] mtv
and [ __ ] the labels
it's like no [ __ ] excuses get in
studio make a song
put it out dm a thousand influencers
hope somebody shares it
[ __ ] then let the market decide like
i know everybody gets mad at me for
saying like the same advice
it's the right advice it's like how you
get into better shape
exercise and eating right sorry sorry
that's what it is
so let's get straight in so tell me
let's we're talking about authenticity
in a brand what does it mean to you from
a brand communication
you know this is an interesting question
i have a pretty
for this world a pretty left field point
of view on this
and my point of view is that we need to
achieve relevance
i'm looking at 11 12 13 faces right now
and what pepsi or bmw or coca-cola
or facebook means to all these people is
actually different
and so for me authenticity gets very
close to relevancy because when you're a
big brand
there are so many variables in your
world there's so many things that you're
doing
you know some people may drink a cola to
get a burst of energy others
it may be a reminder of spending time
with their grandmother
and i think we're so literal in today's
brand and marketing world
we're so stuck on sentences and
adjectives and we spend so much time
on subjective things that don't matter
to the consumer on the other end so my
perspective is
much like a human being you and i are
gonna act differently right now as
humans
in this interview than if we were with
our family than if we were on a weekend
in las vegas with our best friends
than if we were presenting to 5 000
people people always like gary you're a
little bit different
than when you i see you on video i'm
like yeah i'm on stage to 7
000 people versus i'm here with you
there's different
versions and i think people struggle in
ad land
to understand things are
multi-dimensional
and so for me authenticity is actually
being comfortable
in the 74 to 7 400 variations of how you
show up
and so i think that we are that human
beings
executives are limiting brands ability
to be authentic
because they want it to be so literal
and so safe
and so pr'ed and so approved by the
queen bee
that uh that i think we live in a very
non-authentic world
and i think the reason humans continue
to scale in popularity
is they're a focus group of the audience
they're uh they're a they're an
executive group of one
and i i think one of the reasons real
celebrities are struggling
and have lost share is they do have pr
people they do have big deals with movie
studios that they're scared of
breaking and so i think anyone who could
actually show
all the versions of themselves will win
and i think right now
the creative industry a isn't set up to
make enough creative
b has way too much b2b dna in it to
actually show up authentic
and this is not schizophrenia this is
not throw up against the wall and see
what sticks this is not being
scattered this is being true and so
i think authenticity uh has a far more
uh at its end there's always a something
that delivers at the end a piece of
content
or creative and i think it's being far
more wide
than it's been over the last 80 years
the reason i have that feeling towards
you as far as
more of a friendship even though we've
never never met before don't know each
other
is authenticity you get you see somebody
on social media and you're like that's
that's a good dude right there well and
you know and
you and i got to hang out at age 2021
and in mobile um
there is a level of humility to you that
you can
sense in person absolutely way more than
you can unveil
yes and it's almost it's almost by the
way i apologize for interrupting
i'm like desperate to meet everybody
because to your point and i'm sure you
didn't sense that when i was talking
directly to you
it's when you got to watch me work a
room
in my natural state prep for going on
stage
i know that about me i know literally
last night i was telling my parents
literally last night that the one thing
that i'm on i was telling them how i
don't like somebody
let me phrase because it's not the truth
that i don't respect somebody that
is a very famous business person because
they're just not nice
and i was saying last night because my
dad was in a room we had an employee
once steal
700 000 worth of wine from us and i said
that i would forgive that person
tomorrow if they called me and help them
which drives my dad crazy but i said but
if i saw somebody be unkind to a cashier
at burger king
it's a death blow i can never have a
real relationship with them again
um you know i assume i mean you can jump
in here but
you got to see it when i knew you
weren't watching which then leads to the
truth well
you know what it was for me was we had
just got back from cuba i remember
and you get pulled away right after we
told you
we got back from cuba you talk to
everybody in the room
and you come back so tell me more about
cuba it's like genuinely care
you know and it's and it's almost i
don't want to say
off-putting but it's it's like because
you're expecting
bravado and you know things like that
but it's like wow that's a really nice
freaking dude you know it's it's funny
when social started happening i'm like
ooh this is gonna be good for me because
what i knew is i genuinely like people
like for example when i came into this
room i didn't say hello
because i'm strategically thinking when
you leave you'll tell everybody that
garyvee's nice i said hello because it's
my natural being
that's what cuba was it's exhausting to
try to game it
right sure you can't game it i would
highly recommend
uh you focus on sales you have to figure
out can you sell your thing
whatever that is it's a service sell out
the show
your thing that you actually sell if
you're not capable of selling
as a solopreneur there's really nothing
else that matters because
money intake is the way you continue to
the next move
right it's it's it's like up up down
down left right left right baba select
start
powers up your lives and contra like you
need
lives and cash is that nintendo cheat
sheet hack
and so that's what it is cash is oxygen
cash say with me vayner nation cash is
oxygen cash is oxygen
super important i see this from
entrepreneurs
to the biggest companies in the world
i'm fascinated that we don't have more
sophisticated conversations
of separating branding and marketing and
sales
for how many people here follow me and
like my stuff great
what you guys are feeling is branding
you're feeling branding
i'm paying out to build a halo effect of
what garyvee means it's why you like it
because i'm not selling you the selling
that branding comes is when my book
comes out in
january this year you're gonna feel some
wear between
guilt because i gave it all away for
free to just
passionate and want to support somewhere
between there
which creates a sale i
know that but here is the most important
thing this is where everybody [ __ ]
breaks down
because i see some faces that i know and
this is where people break down on my
thing i give everything away for free i
hope it creates brand
and then i have moments of whether my
sneaker that's coming out on my birthday
in november this year
or a book in january or something else
i hope and think and expect
and would like to think it converts into
sales
but here's the single most important
thing
if it doesn't convert i am not crippled
where people struggle is they give with
expectation
of return youtube watcher what's up it's
garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you